[Music]
let's move on to olivia she's on the
line in miami florida olivia welcome to
the ramsay show
hi george hi john how are you doing
great how can we help
so i recently moved to florida and uh
my rent actually increased um i've been
following financial peace university
since 2020 but i didn't really um
kind of follow all the rules so i kind
of messed up and got myself a little bit
deeper into debt so i kind of started uh
doing it all over again and uh but my
rent increased and i'm i'm thinking um
should i put the baby steps on hold and
focus on it finding a cheaper apartment
or should i just stay where i am for now
well i don't think this is an emergency
situation where we put the steps on hold
what we do have to do is look at our
budget and find margin and there's only
two ways to create that margin number
one is increase our income and number
two is decrease our expenses
and the combination of those things
hopefully will get you to a point where
you're going to be able to afford that
rent and keep on with the baby steps so
when you say you did something dumb
what'd you do
i got a car i financed the car oh you're
calling about can i get a cheaper
apartment and then you made a what's
this car like what is it
yeah
uh i so i got a a car loan in 20 like
2020
um so that ended up kind of being the
mistake there so it's kind of the
expense of paying for the car and
student loans and credit cards and
everything it's just kind of kicking my
butt plus plus the inflation well the
good news about cars is that it's
usually a reversible decision so what's
the car worth
the car right now uh the last time i
tried i checked it was like 10 000
but my my car payments are 15. like the
total i should say is 15 000. so the
loan is for fifteen thousand dollars
yes and the car is only worth ten
yes i would go check on that that feels
really low since you bought that in 2020
cars have appreciated in the most
bizarre way have you checked on it
recently
yeah i have because i was trying to
trade it in for something um cheaper and
uh they would it turned out that i would
have negative equity so
okay so what's your take-home pay right
now every month
it's uh i take home about 20 uh sorry i
take home 2 000 a month
and what's your rent
my rent is 12.50 ouch you can't even
breathe olivia what are you doing
i know is this a one-bedroom apartment
yeah
okay and you're living alone obviously
yes okay it may be time to
move out and move in with someone else
as a roommate
have you thought about that option
i actually just came out of a roommate
situation so i kind of didn't want to go
back into that okay olivia let me say
this because george is really kind you
are broke
you're drowning
you can't breathe okay how do we get
this income up is another part of the
equation
you definitely have to move out you
can't afford this even if you got a
raise today this is insane to be paying
this much with your take-home pay
yeah so what are you doing for work
i work in uh pharmacy as a pharmacy tech
okay
and you're making 24 a year after taxes
uh 30 a year after taxes
okay i think we need to find a way to
get this income up yeah maybe the
temporary so he here's what happened you
found yourself and you're broke
you followed america to florida and
shockingly when all of america wants to
live in a place then the rents go way up
and they can just move them up
willy-nilly because there's a line of
people from california new york who will
take that spot behind you
you're gonna have to be radical for a
season in a season i mean probably two
years
and i mean radical like you're gonna
work a full day as a farm tech and then
you're gonna go over work another shift
at a local hospital or you're gonna go
deliver uh pizzas you're gonna you drive
for lyft you're gonna do whatever for
two years
and you're gonna
pay this sucker off and pay your stupid
student loans off and you're gonna have
a knuckleheaded roommate that's so
annoying
they're safe but god almighty they're
annoying
in every day you're gonna say never
again never again never again
you hear what i'm saying
yeah
how old are you
i'm 26.
just close your eyes for a second real
tight and think about being 28 and not
own anybody anything as you move into
your new apartment and you'll have
gotten a new job because you're going to
have so much new muscle
you'll be a gangster
like you know what i mean that like so
yeah i know i'm sounding like man that
guy needs to take a couple of xanax and
chill out i know i sound like that but i
don't know you realize how scary things
are for you
yeah i actually do realize
but like my budget has been really tight
like i've been really good with my
budget so i've been just been able to
kind of stay afloat but it's it's really
hard yeah have you gone through
financial peace university
i have i just started um the baby steps
i'm at baby step one good awesome well
how much debt do you have total
in total it's about
48 000. okay
you can do this but like john's saying
you're gonna have to do some radical
things sacrifice get the roommate take
the second job take the third job get
your income up slash the budget even
further for a season
six and a half days a week and if you
can sacrifice for two years the next 20
after that are going to be amazing 30 40
after that 50. we'll keep going to live
forever she's going to go forever that's
financial freedom well we're pulling for
you thanks for the call